every April car lovers flocked to Essen
Germany for the techno classica it's the
world's leading trade fair for classic
and vintage automobiles here you can
find fully restored and extremely
expensive classy cars alongside those
that hope to be classic someday hi this
ferrari dealer says when it comes to a
classic like this fully restored
essentially means rebuilding the car
from scratch and that's reflected in the
price in place some of the vehicles on
show here change hands for several
million euros but most people will never
be able to call one their own outside of
the exhibition halls the price tags are
lower you'll still see the odd car in
the 100,000 euro range like this Ferrari
308 GTS but others are more affordable
it's been this man retired last year and
is looking for a hobby he'd like to find
a car that's not been restored one he
can rebuild assets when DS 20 or DS 21
or maybe a humpback vulval it was a
Salesman so he has no professional
experience but figures he can pick
things up on his own McKenzie go for
this unlikely this year the electronics
and modern classics is a hot topic at
the show
he's a electronic he says they're
looking into the issue in future they
might be able to update devices and
rework the electronics until four or
five years ago they thought it wasn't
possible but now they've changed their
minds he says we'll see times are
changing before they also said old
carburetors were beyond repair now they
just manufacture the parts and fix them
heart defect unit island on the vet
career anions bubble car clubs are
represented here to their members are
happy to show off their pride and joy
many have remained true to the same
brand for decades
this man says they're the cars we knew
in our youth the ones we learn to drive
with and they've stuck with them the
techno classica could also be called the
world's biggest spare parts depot
dealers from across Europe have parts to
fit almost every model ever made
collectors can also pick up diecast
models and other automotive memorabilia
some car manufacturers are also
promoting their brands history this year
Porsche has brought along its 9 24 9 44
and 968 transaxle models this red 924
was the design prototype for the
successful model it's a museum piece and
not for sale the head of the porsche
museum says yeah transex transaxle has
the motor up front and transmission and
back it was a milestone in Porsches
development another eye-catching car at
the Porsche stand is this 911 2.5 st
which won many a race in its day back
then its owner Michelle Kaiser and
Porsche factory racing driver Juergen
Bart took turns behind the wheel
she stood up the head of Porsche classic
tells us that a Swiss collector
discovered this car in the US and a
state of utter disrepair parked in a
field children used to play in it
luckily someone checked the car serial
number and realized what a treasure they
were jumping around it he's glad the car
eventually found its way to the Porsche
works and zuffa now see who shot stylish
disputes let's ante fantin through clear
visor the spots like silent week soo ins
not sew philosopher it took two years of
hard work to return the 911 to its
original condition hundreds Porsches uba
Makovsky explains that it's not a
regular series production model but one
that was specially modified for racing
so you couldn't just open up a repair
manual and see how it worked they had to
do tons of research and ask people who
were involved in the project back then
was deluded a fog dee da machine will be
upon in the projector you don't have to
be an antique car enthusiast to enjoy a
visit to the techno classica but looking
around at these gleaming cars of
yesteryear you might just become one